hi there steve here uh it's been a while
since i made a video
uh i'm very happy that uh alex at uh at
our link headquarters there was able to
get my imovie to work again he fixed
some settings i'm just as happy as can
be
uh thank you for all those people who
said when are you going to do another
video blah blah blah well here i am so
today i'm just going to ramble a bit
i had a lovely uh two months in europe
uh traveling was my 65th birthday my
wife and i traveled we were in germany
uh portugal spain briefly in france and
mostly in italy
uh and it's lovely to travel in a
country where you speak the language i
don't know how people enjoy traveling
in countries for any length of time
where they don't speak the language
i particularly wanted to spend a lot of
time in italy to try and raise the level
of my italian and i had an interesting
experience there because i really didn't
have a chance to speak a lot of italian
while there because i was with my wife
and we were driving and visiting
all the sites and we'd be we'd go out to
dinner together at night and mostly we
were with each other
so and a lot of the people in the hotels
and restaurants spoke english i was
quite surprised
and they were quite intent on speaking
english so but i still managed to speak
a certain amount of italian
but what i noticed was that because i
was listening to italian in the car i
had our
link lessons on that i was listening to
and um
i would read the newspaper every day
over coffee and there would always be a
little bit of italian and then some days
i'd be lucky in that i would meet people
uh italians that i would have to speak
to and so forth but
what i found was when i came home my
italian was much improved
uh before leaving i had listened to
an audiobook from il naratore and i
recommend
illnaratore.com as the place to get your
italian audiobooks
and
there is a particular italian book la
provinciale by alberto moravia which i
had listened to before leaving and there
were many parts in it that i had trouble
understanding when i came home i
listened to it i understood 99 of it
and and what i ascribed that to is that
i was in a situation for a month
where italian was real
it wasn't just
you know listening to stuff while
jogging in vancouver i was in the
environment i was communicating it was
on a day-to-day basis the italian was
real mostly i was just listening and
reading uh occasionally speaking and i i
believe that does something that does i
i want to read more about how our
emotions
affect and our feelings affect our
ability to learn
but i just think it made italian more
real it made it more natural it wasn't
something i was studying it was
something that i was doing
and so when i came home i i found that i
had stepped up my italian by quite a bit
so that was one thing i wanted to
mention
another thing i want to mention is uh
you know every time we have a new tutor
at link i like to sign up for a
discussion
uh and so we have new tutor uh i won't
mention which language two new tutors in
this one language so i signed up with
both of them
and i explained our system which is uh
you know just
write down all the words and phrases
that i misuse and then send them to me
in our report i save it
and then i save as i import it into link
and i save the words and faces that i
need and i i still remember what i said
in our discussion and so i see aha that
was wrong and then i save it and
it'll show up highlighted in yellow and
when i read again and so gradually i'll
get used to that word or that phrase
uh one of the tutors did that the other
one
wrote me a lot of
you know explanations in english
of what i did wrong and i i must say my
reaction to that was well first of all
having the english on the text is is not
convenient because then i can't import
it into link because it it messes up our
statistics but the other thing is
she was too much of a teacher
and maybe it's just me
but
if i look at the mistakes
that are corrected i would say they fall
into different categories
uh
sometimes they're just terrorist
mistakes it's something that i may get
correct eighty percent of the time and
wrong
twenty percent of the time so i don't
need a lengthy explanation
it's sufficient to see it the correct
way and i'll remember oh yeah right
that's how i was
supposed to say that
uh some things maybe i don't want to do
well let's face it this language was
portuguese so one of the issues was in
spanish we say preguntar and in
portuguese
i know that but i'll occasionally get it
wrong while i'm speaking because i'll
confuse my italian authorities yeah
italian spanish portuguese so i don't
need the explanation it's sufficient
just to say later on i read oh i said
this yeah that reminds me i've got to
try harder to remember to say per guntar
when i was speaking quickly but it
doesn't affect communication it's really
not a big deal if i were to spend if i'm
in portugal for or brazil for two or
three weeks it'll all be paired with our
but having just come from
uh visiting in spain and so forth
but
i don't need the explanation another one
was that the r she said you have to
pronounce it like as if i'm scratching
my throat which is how they pronounce it
in brazil and in certain parts of
portugal but maybe i don't want to make
that sound so it raises the other issue
is what are the goals
and then i used some of the pronouns
wrong you know
or mayo whatever but she said you should
go back and study your pronouns or maybe
you don't want to study the pronouns in
other words with too much teaching
i find that teacher takes the initiative
away from the student maybe i don't want
to speak maybe i just spoke
occasionally i want to speak it may
mainly maybe my main interest is just to
understand
maybe i don't want to pronounce with
that r that scratches my throat
it's my language in other words i learn
it the way i want to learn it now that's
of course
a bit idealistic because in school you
have to pass tests and it's the teacher
who determines
what your standard is going to be what
you're going to learn how you're going
to pronounce
and so really the teacher ends up taking
away
the pleasure that pleasure of
independent study that i have when i'm
learning a language so that's why
i mean there are there are other reasons
i also think that that the corrections
don't help you know go and study your
pronouns well i've looked at them i've
seen those tables
uh it's only slowly that it's eventually
going to become natural to me
so if i want to go look at the tables i
know where they are i'll go look at them
uh it's sufficient
to simply uh the way we do it that link
is just write out all the phrases that i
got wrong i'll look at them here all the
phrases that you got wrong and here's
how you're supposed to say them i see
that only in the target language i
import i'll say away i go i don't need a
lot of explanations some explanations
are confusing many of them are
unnecessary
plus but always has this this impression
that you know whenever the teacher is
active teaching like i know something
that you don't know i will teach it to
you
that to me is less
motivating than
i am discovering the language
i am on this exploration speaking of
which i'm now into korean
because i said way back in september
that i would do korean and this is a
korean challenge and we've got korean
and link and i'm going to see how much i
can learn by christmas time but in
reality we got so little content put up
in link we have more now
but in those days it was so slow to come
plus then i was traveling so i really
did nothing
but now i've decided to go at it again
and i'm really enjoying it and what i
should have actually brought an example
but it is so great doing it on the ipad
because
basically what i have now is i don't do
the lessons in link i i click on all the
words that i need
but then i and i but then i only read
and and listen on my ipad sitting
comfortably
uh in
in a sofa and since i've already gone
through these texts and pick out all the
work picked out all the words that i
need that i don't understand and these
now highlight in yellow when i read and
listen on my ipad so i listen to the
text i read the text on my ipad i've
done i've been through like this this
one series 26 episodes of this silly
story
i've gone through it five or six times
there's still parts that i just don't
get
i can look up the words again oh yeah
right
and i'm going to go through it 15 20
times but at the end of it
i'll have a better sense of structure in
in korean but it's just me and the
language no explanations no examples no
nothing it's just this text the sound
the words and me and i'm just this is
very intense interaction
with this body of content and when i'm
through with that i'll go through to
some other content but it is neat to be
able to sort of intensely interact with
the language just the words the sounds
and how it's written
and i'll keep at it until i
kind of understand 70 80 of it and i'll
go into something else so here you have
it i've rambled a bit uh i just wanted
to i was so happy that my imovie is
working again i thought it's late here
but before going to bed
uh yeah i watched the vancouver canucks
beat the st louis blues have a nice
dinner before going to bed i would do a
video since my imovie is working again
and we'll see if i can get this loaded
up on youtube thank you for listening
and i'll be back tell you what you want
me to talk about dude
bye for now